hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to jack box party pack 5
thank you for joining me you can play
this game with me it's called patently
stupid what it does is we create a bunch
of problems and then we draw a solution
to it and then poop jokes ensue dick
jokes ensue all sorts of immature humor
so if you are of a high brow level of
humor please leave now you are not
welcome here this is childish humor only
only people with a mental age of 7 and
below are welcome here so buckle the
[ __ ] up here we go this is my ex-wife
Lena and together we are about to change
your lives Wow that's right Lena we've
got a packed room of eight but this room
is packed with future millionaires yeah
now everybody knows the best inventions
solve big problems and to identify those
big problems we'll need to do a little
market research on your device you're
going to receive to fill in the blank
prompts type in anything at all now your
problems getting sent to the other
attendees to inspire their creative
masterpieces so let's get to it I think
there's something about these
announcements that just makes this game
hilarious
just the way they inflect things some
other people that are watching we're
just filling in the blanks here but your
ethics might be getting in the way of a
good idea I've always thought that
ethics needed to go out the window when
we're playing things like this simply
pick the one you want to solve where you
bring your designs to life using nothing
but a pen and paper okay ran out of
paper so you'll have to use some
cocktail napkins okay and don't forget
to spice it up with a little color all
right okay I'm ready for this okay I got
it I got it guys and I'm trying to avoid
the the default strategy of mine which
is just to put dicks into everything
that I do so I'm hoping that I can kind
of avoid that as much as I possibly can
okay so now let's bring it all home give
it a title also recommendation to
everybody playing in the in the actual
game let them do that do the
presentation they do the best job on the
presentation don't rush me I'm trying
really hard okay I got it I got it I got
this one whoa damn [ __ ] I'm not too
proud of my I don't think mine's the
best that it ever was I think I could've
done better
yourself - this is no time to be shy
exactly Lina now let's see those
inventions
let's see them let's see what we got all
right kid moon you got it
let's see what you got let them do it
Dan clear and watch us work Toby seems
like you have a problem you bet I do
Lina this happens well I think I've got
just the right solution it's just a
little thing called yeah that sounds
great
but what does it look like glad you
asked take a look at this all right god
damn it mines gonna be crap by
comparison oh god here we go present it
for me myself whatever
look I sure do Lina I just
call does it look like well take a look
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and seen at least you own up to right if
you don't have artistic skills you gotta
own up do it everyone for you it's just
a little thing called yeah that sounds
great
take a look for yourself
without a tab line I'm afraid I just
won't remember it draw people's eyes
towards your Magnum dong is garbage
that's garbage if ever there was one oh
you son of a [ __ ] don't do it no don't
do it what's it look like
glad you asked that's the idea and
that's how it's done every think it's a
leg each of you has been given some
money token give your largest chip to
your favorite invention largest your
second favorite and so on never stop
being me are you telling me to never
stop being my height is that what you're
saying cuz I will not or I will or I
won't I'm not sure which one no let's
see which inventions are destined for
greatness
you'll need to acquire $1200 in capital
to not only fund your invention but also
net yourself a 500 dollar funding bonus
in a successful invention and get double
your money back but if it fails they
keep your cash let's see how you did
[Music]
hell yeah hell yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yes I find it do good ones hell yeah
instead of solving different problems
you all tackle the same this is the
situation that rose up the other one put
my art into this one I really got to try
real hard guys don't mess it up don't
mess it up don't mess it up don't ever
mess this up Cali you better not mess
this up I swear if you mess this up we
will all collectively smack ya okay I
got it
okay I did it took me a [ __ ] but I
think I got it here we go all right
kiddin moon hey dobe it looks like you
have a problem you bet I do Lena my this
keeps coming back
yeah that sounds well take a look silly
[Laughter]
but without a tagline I'm afraid it's
done everybody well I think I've got
just the right
my prayers have been answered but oh
well take a look silly it looks like
some penis scented perfume oh they're
gonna save me for last aren't they it's
just a little thing called the sequel
ooh alright go for it something I like
to call that sounds like a perfect
solution what's it look like well take a
look silly
[Music]
this looks great Lena but without a
tagline I'm afraid I just won't remember
it not to worry my easily influenced
friend
four days it sure will and that's how
it's done everybody you bet I do Lina is
bad I can only remember things that's
the idea and scene we're gonna do this
again
this is no time to be shy exactly now
let's see those inventions all right all
right
Timothy let's see what you got it looks
like you have a problem you bet I do
Lena I need a place just for my this
that is a problem but I think I've got
just what you need it's something I like
to call
yeah that sounds great but what does it
look like well take a look silly but
Lina won't forget about this in five
minutes it sure will and that's how it's
done everybody funny that's not funny
that's not funny
I sure do Lina that'll be stuck in my
head for days darn straight just stop
doing well but what's it look like take
a look for yourself in my head for days
that's the idea
and scene you can't bring this on pal
she called me anyways long story short
okay don't give me that look okay okay
fine
so I get arrested and they broke my face
true story
well I think I've got just the right
solution it's just a little thing called
[Music]
look at this oh that's amazing
this looks great Lina but without a tag
line I'm afraid I just won't remember
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
angry that's a doozy well have I got
just the thing for you it's simply
called
that sounds like a perfect solution
what's it look like well take a look
silly
my brain is bad I can only remember
things that have a tag line stuck in my
head for days that's the idea great job
I think I think just like bad job
crosses poor now let's see which
inventions fix you in the ass might
drive some people wild but for the wrong
reasons damn it said dammit I can't
believe that one didn't win you simply
select don't ruin it don't roll in it
good choice oh okay you know what's next
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh I sure do Lina I hate having to do
morning that's a doozy well have I got
just the thing for you
it's something I like to call bad I can
only remember things that have a catchy
tagline
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I think I've got just the right
solution and that's how it's done
everybody well have I got just the thing
for you it's something I like to call
my prayers have been answered but what's
it look like
glad you asked take a look at this
Picasso couldn't have drawn it better
himself for days darn straight and seen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
take a look for yourself it's almost
like this actually tried to make a
product and not focus on the actual sake
of Lena I hate having to do this in the
morning well I think I've got just the
right solution it's something I like to
call perfect solution what's it look
like well take a look silly Lena but
without a tagline I'm afraid I just
won't remember it well you're in luck
oh boy that'll be stuck in my head for
days darn straight and seen oh god I'm
gonna get banned I'm gonna get banned so
fast thank you for nothing thank you for
being horrible horrible people all right
Rick boy we're all going to hell
Grande provides her own milk and cookies
I thought I was gonna I couldn't breathe
for a second there and I know that
suggests that I'm a horrible person but
I literally legitimately couldn't
breathe mine is the best one it's
legitimate it has almost nothing to do
with the penis okay it might have
everything to do with a penis it might
actually be completely 100% penis it
might actually be 200% penis now that I
think about this but but wait you'll see
you'll see what I got going on it's
smart hey Toby it looks like you have a
problem sure do I don't think anyway I'd
like to think that I'm the best with
coming up with the taglines I think
that's my strong penis attack with that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you tube is watching this I'm sorry I
said you do was broken up I just want to
be this well I think I've got just the
right solution it's something I like to
call what's it look like
glad you asked oh good I don't know who
would want that that's that's not a
problem I have I'm perfectly happy with
my height but I think I've got just what
you need is simply called that sounds
like a perfect solution what's it look
like
glad you asked point your peepers at
this
oh that's amazing but Lena my brain is
bad I can only remember things that have
a catchy tagline that'll be stuck in my
head for days hey thank you I'd like to
think there's no bias in that it's my
artistic abilities really got it through
there Oh
the granny dams where's add the gravy
man was good I liked the granny oh I got
a pick it okay I got one I'm not proud
of what I picked but I picked it okay I
did one that wasn't horribly gross I did
one that wasn't horribly grandma has
nothing not my phone this has nothing to
do with Grandma I've got a very clever
idea and I'm I don't know I keep wanting
to hop up on my stool I think it's just
a instinctive thing to be taller
[Laughter]
why do I make myself laugh I don't know
I'm so sorry I'm such a loser I make
myself laugh more than anybody makes me
laugh but I'm like Ethan there's no one
that makes me laugh harder than my own
prep everybody hurry up okay hurry up
you're a on time pay and out of time I
do this that's a doozy
well have I got just the thing for you
it's just a little thing called yeah
that sounds great but what does it look
like take a look for yourself in the
toilet and scene the problem Jelena but
sure do it's simply called my prayers
have been answered but what's it look
like
glad you asked point your peepers at
this
[Laughter]
and that's how it's done everybody it's
just a little thing called darn straight
and see we done what have we done
tie him up and force him to watch I
think that's the opposite of the
objective were ending here product I've
seen well pitched last time and don't
make it about poop jokes no penis no
poopy sorry I'm I'm not funny I'm not
funny no this isn't a band worthy thing
this is this is comedy genius
this is cleverness this is an invention
that's worth it
come on peony opa ain't gonna be done in
time oh well they ran that time now
let's see those invention oh boy here we
go
all right everybody buckle up hi good
name it looks like you have a problem I
sure do never know how much - oh good
good problem a good problem but what's
it look like
glad you asked tako that's the idea no
no no no no just no you bet I do Lena
these are too tall and it hurts my neck
to look at them not to do Zee well have
I got just the thing for you it's
something I like to call okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's good that's actually clever
that's at not a poop joke
there's no penis in here that's actually
clever oh oh well okay all right hang on
this one mine's not bad in any way I
can't remember what mine is oh yeah wait
no it's bad well I think I've got just
the right solution it's something I like
to call my prayers answered but what's
it look like
glad you asked take a look at this
Picasso did better himself
oh boy that'll be stuck in my head for
days that's the idea and that's how it's
done everybody well take a look that
sounds like a perfect solution what's it
look like
glad you asked Oh fantastic
design and scene he's one of the people
that ran out of time isn't it hard and
that's how it's done everybody I like
this one because there are some
perfectly normal ones things that
weren't weird all at all completely
innocent there's nothing wrong with any
of this it's all fine it's all innocent
and there's nothing wrong with any of it
that surprisingly I did not think that
was get funded yes I need a totally
normal hat I really do no I must start a
Kickstarter for the totally normal hat
very soon be on the lookout for that
what do you got why does it have to be I
[ __ ] eggs why do you have to get that oh
okay I got mine I'm real proud of mine
mine's as wholesome as something can be
when you can't stop attracting wild
penis there we go this is it
witsand from attracting this that's a
doozy well I got just the thing for you
it's just a little thing called that
sounds like a perfect solution what's it
look like well take a long oh that's
amazing but Lina won't forget about this
in five minutes and scene oh here we go
okay all right you know what you know
what I'm gonna I'm actually gonna do
this one myself I'm gonna do is one
myself okay all right have you ever run
into this problem where you always be
attracting wild penis any underbrush
wherever you go penis left right up down
south penis in all directions well let
me introduce you to the penis pokeball
oh yes all of your dreams are come true
when you have the penis pokeball you
absolutely instantly take advantage of
all those penis popping out of the
underbrush and what's the tagline you
ask penis I choose you thank you thank
you this is such a wholesome street take
a look for yourself I can only remember
things
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's just take a look at this hey wait a
minute
[Music]
mine was better mine was better mine can
we copy strike Kevin everybody let's get
the heaven oh god no no wait a minute my
head for days that's the idea and scene
no those my idea
I drew it better I drew it better I'm
new hey hey I drew it better I did
better copy strike
coppy strike them all I have not met my
match my match is not met because I'm
better
hah hah hah hah hah hah thank you thank
you fair fair enough oh really oh
[Music]
alright well then well that's just a
load of bull honky that's a load of bull
honky if I've ever seen bull honky in my
life so anyway if you want to see more
of me laughing like a stupid idiot go
check out those sleep and slurp that's
what inspired me to do this whole stream
cuz I was like this is so goddamn funny
I have to keep doing this thank you
everybody so much for being here and as
always I will see you bye bye bye guys
bye
[Music]